hi everyone its Johanna here and today
I'll be showing you a quick 90 seconds
lower abs workout to get rid of that
stubborn muffin top and because this
exercise is so quick but effective I
would encourage you to do it whenever
and wherever you can so whether you just
got out of bed when you're watching your
favorite TV show in the gym at home just
try to slop 90 seconds in to get the
nice Buddha laps so let's get straight
to the workout so we'll be doing three
exercises in 90 seconds and try not to
stop in between those exercises try to
keep going for 90 seconds without
stopping all right so let's start with
the first workout just like I'm going
that we'll just start by warming up so
bring your next 90 degrees and just
crunch in slightly after Laurita and
crunchy right let's warm up for about 10
seconds to 15 seconds
crunching crunching you should start
feeling your lower abs working get the
really start punching and the first
workout is called reverse crunch and
what we want to be doing is trying to
get our views off the floor as much as
you can so there you go up that's it
lift your hips off the floor good up
good keep going this is a first workout
reverse crunch it's really good for your
lower abs if you find this easy trying
to straighten your legs lower it down
and straighten your legs that's it okay
up good last three
last two and last one you top second
workout if your body up and this is
composite so just straighten your legs
and just fun to mix your chapter going
which is not feeling your abs burning
cute
okay just relax our body keep your body
straight and just for kicks
how are you doing remember it's only 90
seconds so try to with yourself as much
as you can
alright good job the last workout keep
your body similar bring it in and March
it out
bring it in and crunch oh good job in
and let's go 20 more seconds in and out
in and in a Smosh energy camp in out in
out
good job keep going last one last three
plus two and last one kill jump there
you go that's my quick 90 seconds lower
abs workout I've only done one set but I
can really feel my lower abs burning but
if you can if you want to push yourself
try to do 3 sets so 90 seconds rest for
about a minute and then do another set
of 90 seconds rest for another minute
and do another set I can assure you that
if you were to do this every day you
will start noticing
that you have flatter and tighter lower
abs so don't forget to subscribe to my
channel for more nutritional and workout
videos thanks guys bye
you